主力最害怕你学会的指标
可能就是obv
因为它是成交量的高阶用法
不仅可以看到主力的吸筹与拉升
还可以判断主力出货
以及一只股票的突破点
今天就把这套方法分享给大家
建议点赞订阅反复学习
今天的视频我们主要讲解三个内容
第一obv的指标原理
第二,OBV操作的六大口诀
第三,OBV的最强用法
如何预知股价何时脱离盘整区
OBV能量潮又被称为平衡交易量
是由美国投资分析家葛兰币在1981年创立的
理论基础是能量是因股价是果
它利用股价和成交量的指标来反映人气兴衰
人为的按照股价的涨跌
将成交量标为正负
并进行累加运算
所以它是一个不错的补装工具
那么为什么它很好用呢
因为它的理论基础是股价变化必须配合成交量
尤其是股价波动与成交量的放大萎缩有密切的关联
所以在图表上就把成交量数量化
做成了趋势线
这样配合股价就能够很好的发现
主力庄家何时在吸筹
何时要拉升
甚至可以预判出股价即将脱离盘整区
这样就做到了先知先觉
我会在今天视频的最后重点讲解
OBV的最强用法
大家一定要看到最后
接下来我们来看一下OBV的六大口诀
第一 OBV从下到上大转向
长线投资可进场
第二 OBV升股价升股价稳步攀高峰
第三 OBV轻彩AOBV黑马即将炒上飞
第四 OBV升得急向下拐头要小心
第五 OBV出散户坑主力洗盘
意图名
第六
OBV跌股价跌早点分手早解脱
我们来看第一个案例
图中的白线就是OBV线
而黄色线是默认的OBV均线
参数是30
这里的股价经过长期下跌之后开始震荡
而下面的OBV指标黄色的均线出现了下降走平到上升的走势
在这之前我们也能看到白色OBV线上穿了OBV均线
所以在经历了这个转变之后
我们就可以确定长线投资是一个不错的买点和机会
果然后面也出现了不错的上涨
接下来我们来看一个美股案例
这是爱森美孚在2020年11月到12月的走势
当时的石油股很多人还没有想到能够涨到如今的高度
但当时的走势股价经过下跌之后开始出现上涨
而下面的OBV指标已经明显是黄线由下降走平到转上
这是明确的反转走势
而之前的白色线也经过了两次上穿黄色均线
如果在这里确认大的方向转变
长线入场的话
这里的成本也不过38美金左右
那么后面的涨幅一直到现在是非常不错的
我们来看第二条
OBV升股价升股价稳步攀高峰
很明显图表的走势是一个强势上升趋势
偶尔出现短线回调
但不断的创新高
下面的OBV指标白线始终保持在向上的黄色均线之上也是不断创新高所以这是暴住牛股的最佳黄金波段
不要轻易的乱乱卖掉股票
我们来看一个具体案例
就是波音在2022年10月到2023年1月的走势
很明显大量时间波音的价格走势都是很强势的
偶尔出现过三到五天的回调
幅度不大
但很快能够继续上升
甚至创新高
而下面的成交量衍生指标
OBV就更不用说了
那白线几乎一直向上创新高
而且回调也比较小
而且回调幅度也比较小
这就是为什么有的股民
在最近的几个月操作波音
能够获得相对较大的收益
并且跑赢了大盘
绝对超过了大多数的散户投资者
第三条
OBV青彩AOBV
黑马即将草上飞
普通的白色箭头
股价经历了两到三周的回调
而下面的OBV指标非常明确
白色线几乎回调之后
非常靠近OBV
这就算是青彩均线
而后面的这个位置
虽然出现了短暂的一到两天
白线低于向上的黄色均线
但很快回到黄线之上
这也是OBV青彩均线
都是黑马炒上飞的经典买点
所以在这里买入之后
股价也出现了快速的强势拉升上涨
我们来看一个美股的具体案例
这是特斯拉反指在2022年9月到2023年1月的走势
途中的第一个白色圆圈锁住位置
白色的OBV线正好回调触到黄色线
立即上升
买入之后两到三周立即上涨超过20%
而后面的两个白色圈圈位置
虽然有三天以内低于黄色线
但很快能够回到黄色线上
这也是经典的黑马炒上飞的买点
买入之后也有一个非常强势的上涨
而这里的粉色圆圈位置
很明显白线持续低于黄线时间
超过了三天
这绝对不是黑马炒上飞
那么这是什么呢
一会儿我们将会讲解的第五个口诀
你就会明白
我们来看一下第四个口诀
OBV升的急向下拐头要小心
这里非常明确出现了六个连续上涨的大阳线
可以说股价涨的急
而OBV升的更急
因为他快速拉升远离了黄色均线
后面在这个位置立即出现了拐头向下
这就是一个非常棒的短线卖点
我们来看一个具体的美股案例
这是疫苗股
莫德纳在2022年12月15日出现的一个经典中短线的淘顶信号
为什么这么说呢
首先在这个淘顶信号出现之前
该图表先是出现了两天的急速下跌
随后又出现了两天的报复性上涨
创出新高
但在12月15日这一天
出现了十字星配阳线的走势
这是一个高位运线
但仅仅靠运线
我们不能证明这里很危险
但下面的成交量衍生指标
OBV白色线
急速拉升远离黄色均线
然后向下拐头
这时我们就有理由相信量价配合
这是一个非常棒的中短线卖点而随后股价立即下跌反弹之后开始了快速的大跌所以说这个方法非常适合那些波动比较大
极不稳定的股票
帮我们很好的回避中短线的重要高点
口诀5
OBV出散户坑
主力洗盘一图名
那么什么是散户坑呢
首先我们在使用这个方法之前
先要在图表上放上一条对应的均线
股价出现了一段时间内
持续低于均线的走势
并且均线在短时间内也出现了方向向下
这是一个比较危险的信号
而很多散户如果根据股价低于均线
并且均线方向向下
那么在这里卖出不但没有回避下跌
反而正好卖在了回调低点
那么如何避免这样的散户坑
或者说如何能够利用这样的散户坑
正好买到后面的拉升
这时我们就要用到OBV了
我们仔细看这两个回调位置
股价方面都出现了价格低于均线
均线向下是一个不好的标志
但仔细想一想
这两个位置的真正股价低于均线的时间
应该是少于三周的
而同时我们看到下面的成交量衍生指标
OBV虽然也出现了白线低于黄色均线
但仔细看黄色均线大部分时间方向是向上的
而且黄色均线偶尔走平
并不影响我们大的分析
从来没有出现过黄线方向向下
比较激进的客户可以一直持股
如果是比较稳健的客户
可以在股价低均线时少量减仓
而一旦确认这里只是洗盘
那么就可以在股价回升到均线之后再买回来
所以别忘了好马也吃回头炒
在实战中我个人更偏向于将
OBV的参数改成机构专用参数
那就是34
因为34是靠近默认参数30的飞薄纳基数字
往往效果更好
同时在这个图标里
我将均线也改成了34天参数
那么这个美股是第一太阳能
在2022年10月7日到26日出现了一段回调
股价呢是低于34天均线
持续时间没有超过三周
也就是不超过15个交易日
而下面的OBV指标明显证明了
上面是一个洗盘的散户坑
原因就是虽然OBV白线也低于了黄线
但黄线一直没有出现任何的向下
大量时间都是走平或者向上的
所以一些股民如果之前没有这只股票
是完全可以在这个位置进行短线进场的
而如果之前买入较低的股民朋友
完全可以在这个位置回调时
不用理会他的下跌而一直持股
但前提一定要确认
OBV的黄线是一直走平或者向上的
绝对不能是向下的
第六条
OBV跌股价跌早点分手早解脱
这个方法就很清楚了
完全是和第二条的相反用法
那就是股价一直低于均线
方向也向下
明确下跌趋势
而下面的成交量衍生指标
OBV也是白线一直不断创新低
OBV均线也一直向下
实在没有什么可讲的
而有的股民如果一直幻想能够发生奇迹
那一定会在下降趋势
输的很惨
我们来看一个具体案例
MEDA在2022年9月到11月份股价虽然在这个位置经历了短暂反弹高于均线但立即向下不断的创新低OPV也是出现了白线短暂上穿黄线
但立即下跌不断创新低
这就是明明白白真真切切的弱势走势
大家切不可心存幻想
因为一旦心存幻想将会出现大量的亏损
而追悔莫及
看完了以上的六大口诀
接下来我们来讲一讲
什么是OBV的最强用法
提前预知股价即将脱离盘整区
也许你会觉得很惊讶
但听我讲完之后
你一定会恍然大悟
这个方法的原理就是量在价先
尤其在真正的底部形成区间
成交量的表现往往是高于早于
价格的
或者说比价格更加可靠
但是不要忘了
一天两天的走势
是不能解决问题的
而且如果你只看成交量的图表
是很难看出真正的门道的
而通过OBV指标
将成交量变成了线性图表
就非常清楚了
这里的波音
在2022年10月25日出现了
OBV的数值突破了整个近几个月内的平台高值
也就是突破OBV的弹整区
而对应的股价区间
显然在10月25日这一天
股价离整个震荡区间的高点还有很远
但这时我们看到OBV却率先摆脱了横摆区
这说明量债价先
真正的资金买方力量
已经在最近的几个月提前进场
并且开始启动了
而我们在价格上却还看不到任何的变化
果然随后的两个多月的时间
波音的涨幅至少达到了40%以上
是不是很神奇呢
今天的方法我们依然是免费分享
同时一定要记住要把OBV的参数改成34
也就是菲博拉基数字的机构参数
希望大家能够多多帮我点赞和转发
让更多的股民朋友可以学到这个神奇方法
我们再来看第二个案例
这是阿里巴巴在2023年1月3日这个位置
OBV明确突破了近几个月的横摆区间
但是我们可以看到在1月3号价格离整个横摆区的峰值高位还有一段距离
但是从1月3号之后到最近
它的股价也是一直在上涨
这就是OBV的最强用法
提前预知未来股价大概率将突破盘整区
原因是刚才我讲到的量在价先
尤其是尤其是注底的时候
这个方法特别好用
接下来我们来总结一下
OBV最强用法的几个注意事项
首先横盘的时间不要早于三个月
时间越长越好
另外股价尚未脱离横摆区
但OBV已经明确的率先突破了横摆区
这里再次强调一下
参数一定要改成34
最后一点如何止损
如果大家拽先买入
那么一定是有风险的
不可能是百分之百
这时就要以OBV数值突破横摆区
那一天的蜡烛最低价作为止损
以上就是我们今天视频的主要内容
有任何问题
欢迎大家在评论区留言
我会尽快为大家一一解答
你的OBV指标也是两条线吗
请在评论区告诉我
我是爱分享股票知识的张璐老师
关注转发加点赞
下期精彩持续看